[Music]
who knows the significance of these
three numbers put together 846 ah yes
or three digits I should think it is the
exact time that Dave Chappelle is born
yes and it's also the name of his new
half hour special that is now available
for free on YouTube so if you haven't
seen it yet I highly recommend and it's
the amount of time that the officer had
his knee oh thank you Tim the most
important significance of these numbers
so yeah like you said that's the amount
of time 8 minutes and 46 seconds that
that police officer ID is me on door
chief Lloyd's neck causing him to die he
got murdered by this officer mm-hmm and
so Dave Chappelle released this new
half-hour special where he pretty much
gives his two cents on the whole thing
has anyone watched it immediately yeah
what do you guys think of it I thought
was really good and um I really liked
how he put it into perspective like he
first came out with his Northridge
earthquake story and it so you're just
talking about how the amount of panic he
felt and even when it was panic he had
to look for his keys his wallet his in
his phone and so it really like you know
when you're in panic mode it really
slows down like when you when you're
like in a car accident you know you have
the whole like ketchup packets in the
air and you have that feeling so he
really slowed it down for you and then
so when I was watching him oh yeah
that's true when you're in like this
life-or-death situation even 30 seconds
seems long and then when he cuts back to
how the officer had his knee on his neck
for eight minutes and 46 seconds I'm
like oh [ __ ] that's an eternity and then
that also made me think wait
cuz I think when you're watching it's
just so much [ __ ] going on unless you're
watching it like 10 times it's really
hard to analyze everything that's
happening when George flood was on the
ground so I'm just having like my
initial primal response right and I'm as
is this just [ __ ] sucks and I turn it
off and I don't watch it over and over
anything yeah but when you're looking it
down and then
got me thinking about how I watched it
before and I'm like when you arrest
someone it's like and they're here in
handcuffs
usually I've been arrested many times
you they put you and they just sit you
back up so he Ortiz he was already in
restraints and for some reason that
guy's knee was still on his neck yeah
the whole time for another eight minutes
and I'm like damn that's [ __ ] crazy
cuz after I think they said after they
checked his it was it definitely checked
this Paul Sartre no no after they are
apprehended him that's a two minutes to
do and then it was still another six
minute forty seconds where his knee was
on his neck so maybe two minutes would
have been justified because they're
trying to detain him but the extra time
I'm like man that's [ __ ] crazy well
there's a video there's a video of
another angle of George Floyd
quote-unquote resisting arrest he's
already handcuffed they're just trying
to put him in the car he's not getting
in the car that's it that's what makes
them go let's put them on the ground put
our knee on his neck for eight minutes
46 seconds
crazy yeah dave has always had a really
good way of putting things into
perspective like even if you weren't on
his side before thinking about that way
he makes you go oh [ __ ] you know cuz you
want to be like that you made me see
like a minute of it on Instagram
and the way he was able to slow it down
like man I was panicking for a minute
during the earthquake I was still
[ __ ] I felt like forever imagine 8
minutes and 46 seconds fearing for your
life he talks about how when his father
I think it was called up for his
grandmother like Dave's that he was like
that's how he knew like George like the
only other time he had ever seen that
was you know with George how he was
calling out for his mom so he had
already known like his end was coming
and like that was really powerful yeah
because he was saying during those 30
seconds of the earthquake he wanted to
scream he didn't want his last moments
to be in that much panic but he was like
imagine the whole eight minutes and
you're like screaming out for your
mother who has already passed away like
knowing that that's what you're calling
off it's a it was funny too cuz like you
know everyone was there for like a Dave
Chappelle special and you could tell it
was like tense though right they're kind
of like oh man how's this gonna go and
like the bigger Dave wasn't really
telling jokes but even when he threw out
the occasion with joke people were kind
of scared to laugh like some of the
cities that would have kill
but like the audience is still really
tense quick at one point he addresses
Karen's without saying Karen but he's
like he's like and white [ __ ] can
y'all just shut the [ __ ] up all the way
I looked at the venue and I'm like I
would just get lit the [ __ ] up by
mosquitoes if I was watching the show
that sounds like it's the only thing
that that stood out to me that it was
like wait do we laugh or do we not yeah
there was a lot but then it was when he
was talking about Kenneth Owens and he
ever gets to smell her [ __ ] you know
just like Azealia oh wait did you
comfort I know who's like I'm at a like
Azealia Banks imma tell the truth we did
not deny yeah one of my favorite parts
is and he was talking about how he was
like you know and these things happen
everyone's asking a celebrity what do
you think what do you think and then
he's like the streets have spoken like
why do you need influencers celebrities
people on Instagram to further estate me
like people already out in the streets
the streets I've spoken and I thought
that was really really powerful because
I notice I've heard a lot of people say
like they're following was demanding for
people to post a black box or demanding
them to do something and then it's like
what's the point of that and I think
they should put there a really good job
of addressing it where it's like right
now there's like some really serious
issues and if you personally believe
this is wrong you personally just go
take action and go do it
don't go well what is this person gonna
think cuz then you're already diverting
your own efforts which I thought was
pretty tired yeah when he was bringing
up Don Don Lemon when he was like
calling out every celebrity was like say
my name [ __ ] I hope you say wait
cuz then for Dave he was like you know
I've been talking about this like all of
my content has been around it it is so
he's like it now was a time for me to
like take it like just like how he
opened it when he said like the youth is
is driving this just fine like I'm I'm
perfectly fine being in the back seat
cuz he was like I've
done whatever I could now the voices
that need to be heard now it's their
time to be heard so why am I gonna step
in and be like no you still have to
listen to me though like I understood
what he was saying so that's the part
that's really sad right after that at
night were like watching Dave Chappelle
and we watched one of his old stand-ups
killing me softly that's the one where
he talks about there's the baby in the
hood or he talks about were cops going
break it I go into his house looking for
the bad guy he goes off you still here
and it's about that microphone because I
wouldn't believe that Dave Chappelle
owns the mansion and half of the set
it's still about police brutality I'm
like damn this was been [ __ ]
preaching about this [ __ ] for 10 15 20
years and nothing has changed well a lot
of people call him Dave Chappelle out or
whatever they don't even they never
watched it they don't know that they
know he did Chappelle's Show print
sketches right they're not even actually
looking at what a person is doing and
they're just pinpointing like oh but you
didn't do this like it was in front of
my face for it for you to shut me up
before I said this that's just people
that want it like instead of taking
action they just want to be more right
or more woke that's why I like online I
was trying to get annoyed more people
were just arguing with each other on the
same side yeah and I was just like why
would you spend more your efforts just
and it's like one they either fight each
other or only talk to each other like
people are already on their side on my
if you want to make a change try to
convince other people do it exactly
everyone's fighting for the mic and then
they're all saying the same thing into
it they're not reaching people like that
so it's not gonna change if you're just
constantly talking to the same people
you just like to hear themselves talk
man that's what it is they want to show
off that they're smart they want to use
big-ass words that just lead to nothing
you know I'm saying like sometimes I
look at two people to like walk ask
people arguing on Twitter and I'm like
turning on what you guys are saying
right now
I'm not like I didn't go to enough
college classes but it's like for the
discussion you know it's hard for me not
to see sincerity and complete and
sincerity in my timeline right now what
I see sincerity and I believe that and
then I see some [ __ ] wack [ __ ] that's
like I'm like you don't think this way
like you're not this person you're doing
this for yourself yeah Candice Owens
replied yeah yeah she she was like
everyone so everyone's sending me clips
of Dave Chappelle insulting me from his
special I'm honest she's like she's like
I'm not one of those people that thinks
comedians shouldn't make fun of people
she's like meeting should make fun of
people and like well I'm look at the
power he said my name I'm honored and
then she goes she's like Dave Chappelle
I'd love to link up and talk about if
you want to say it to my face and she
put Olaf emoji I love most it would have
been [ __ ] great that means she
doesn't yeah she confirmed it it's like
as alien she confirmed it what's all
this alien thing i know-oh-oh cuz banks
you familiar with the daily banks no
she's a rapper singer musician
she's long so we swear she gets into a
lot of like tips she's pretty much only
in the news because she's causing drama
God yeah so she came out a few weeks ago
and was like you know what I should ruin
a lot of these yeah she's like Dave
Chappelle you know we [ __ ]
he got good dick blah blah blah and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] she's just
complimenting she was complimenting him
and while trying to insult him I should
murder I should ruin your marriage yeah
should I should I really should but she
all she talked about how sick his dick
is and like how it was and maybe that's
like you don't want it tonight yeah
any dress is one line if that still kind
of has you going so did they [ __ ] that
is the joke which is great so good he's
so good man good man ah doesn't give a
[ __ ] my hero I disagree with what a lot
of what Candis Owens has to say but I
still really like that she's out there
and being outspoken because she does
have very going against the grain
beliefs um but is it at this point is it
like oh let me make some headlines let
me stir up some [ __ ] but not even be
genuine about it so like her intentions
I don't know I don't know what her
intentions are and I think that's the
power Dave Chappelle says like she's
like a money-hungry ad you know whatever
cuz she is also one of the people that's
trying to grab for headlines yeah I
understand that
white girl - uh Tommy Tommy Larry can we
learn yeah you know so she I mean I
don't know what her intentions are but
her position has been like this for
years and so I like that because it gets
people thinking and so I have come
across some of her videos where maybe I
disagree with majority of it but there's
a couple of really good points that
helps people think more about the
situation because like what Nadine was
saying people they keep fighting over on
the same side but if you don't have
ulterior I mean new perspectives you're
not gonna have new ideas to have new
solutions so it's just two people
circle-jerk it's the situation's bad
yeah it's bad oh it's so bad but what
are the solutions and so for her to go
well what about this I I do
I do respect that there's someone like
her out there seeing stuff I do but I
think she has terrible points about the
Jordan Poyer thing like like hey George
Floyd did some bad [ __ ] so therefore he
could get when he got executed in the
middle of broad daylight like that's
it's okay I don't think she's saying
it's okay but she's like we shouldn't
make him a hero yeah yeah yeah but I'm
like man see that's like also like
diverting your attention to something
that it doesn't matter like what's the
bigger [ __ ] problem here Candice
focus on it seems like she's like for
the Republicans like look we have a
black friend
sometimes I feel like when she does like
talk like obviously I feel like everyone
on both sides always has good points and
there's no one that I think just because
they're on one side they only have bad
points but a lot of times she's like the
stuff I see is like okay how can our
sister be racist if I made it you know
like they have different like you grow
up different there's all these different
things and not saying people from like
the hood can't make it but I just like
your personal your life doesn't mean
that the whole system's fine
yeah and that's in its in Lakeport so
it's an ulterior perspective Morgan
Freeman said the same thing on CNN to
Don Lemon years ago he was like we both
made it that's that's good that's
progress and all that stuff but I don't
even think he's saying there's the
system is not racist in a way he's just
saying like you can make it like yeah
it's good because I think like you know
what the whole George Floyd theme it did
it's one incident right but then there's
Mike grabbers on all sides so you have
Canada's trying to grab the mic and use
it for her agenda because people
grabbing that mic using it for Thera
Genda and because there's there's always
gonna be a Genda I like being able to
hear multiple people talk about things
so you can get a better scope of what
the hell's happening and I just wanna be
able to hear them I don't want people
shouting them down so I can't hear what
they have to say and then I'll just out
those stupid yeah yeah yeah cuz there's
a good chunk of conversation here where
it's like there's a lot of people are
swinging way hard the other way or it's
like you can't even get any sort of
conversation started because now all of
a sudden if I agree with what Steve is
saying just because he's white I'm
seeking for white approval or it's like
no you're just being as racist as what
you're fighting like it makes no sense
it is good to get white approval though
I mean we all want to get any award
[Music]